Newton's second law
states that the sum
of the forces on an object
is equal to the acceleration
of that object times the mass.
But what if instead this
object is actually two objects?
Do I now need to consider
the forces that are acting
between each of these parts?
Or what if I consider
the object to be made out
of even smaller parts?
I can take it down to
its smallest components
and consider the
interactions between all
of the atoms in the object.
This seems like an
overwhelming number of forces
that I'm going to need
to calculate just to find
the force on this object.
But I never seem to
calculate this many forces.
Why is that?
All of these forces between
the atoms in the object
cancel out because they are
Newton's third law pairs.
If both objects are within
the system-- since a Newton's
third law a pair
of forces is equal
and opposite-- the total
force is just zero.
We call these internal forces.
That is, forces that are acting
between a pair of objects that
are both within our system.
On the other hand,
external forces--
forces that act on an object
within the system by an object
outside the system-- are
what we need to consider
for our calculation.
We could be more precise
about Newton's second law
and say that the total
external force on the system
is equal to the system's
acceleration times the system's
mass.
Let's look at an example of
how the selection of a system
will affect the forces
that we need to consider.
I have three blocks.
I'll call them one, two, and
three, and a force that's
pushing block one to the right.
We'll first take a minute
to look at notation.
We will write the forces as F12.
And this means that it's the
force exerted by an object
one acting on an object two.
In this example, I have pairs
of forces between each block.
The interaction between
blocks one and two.
And the interaction between
blocks two and three.
Let's look at the internal and
external forces on the system
if my system is made up of
block one and block two.
I have this external
pushing force-- F
external-- that's acting from
the external pusher on block
one.
Blocks one and two are
interacting with each other.
But these are both
within my system.
So these are internal
forces that I do not
need to worry about.
And finally block two,
which is within my system,
is interacting with block 3,
which is outside my system.
The external force
here is the force
that is acting from
block three on block two.
Now we know that
the two forces that
are relevant to calculating
the motion of the system
are the external
pushing force and F32.
If my system is instead made
up of blocks one and three,
block two is now part of
the extremal environment.
Can you figure out what the
internal and external forces
are?
In this case, the external
forces to the system
are the external pushing force
F external, F21, and F23.